joining me now what else National
Economic Council director Larry Kudlow
all right Larry please break it down for
us these three phases how's it going to
go well look at first of all health and
safety number one criteria for reopening
the economy although I completely agree
we've got to get the economy going again
but health and safety it's going to be
data-driven okay that's the advice and
the guidance that our best doctors and
scientists are going to give to
governors and mayor's across the country
and the basic idea here is we want
fourteen-day declines within every 14
day period you've got to see a decline
in the volume of new cases that's key so
testing is very important surveillance
testing screening diagnostic testing and
of course best practices got to continue
throughout this entire process right
you're gonna have social distancing for
quite some time cleaning your hands
washing up and so forth and so on so
each time you look at a county or a
state or a city whatever and if the
downward movement continues eventually
you go from flattening to adjusting
downward to absolute suppression so
that'll cover the three phases and then
hopefully prayerfully we'll all go back
to work all right so you have schools
opening with distancing you have
restaurants opening with some distancing
maybe a table empty in between something
along those lines and then I guess maybe
phase three you do larger gatherings are
we talking about crowds in Phase three
like you could have people watching a
ballgame well you know I don't want to
be too specific it's not quite that way
it really depends on what the local
authorities are saying and doing but
basically you're right that's the
progression I mean if you're not if
you're well right and you're testing
negative and so forth and you see that
in the aggregate numbers you're gonna be
in good shape
so folks can go back to work
then go back to office buildings they
can go back to their factories they can
reopen schools yes on the conference
calls we had with all the business
leaders two days ago the president heard
the commissioners of baseball for
example talking about reopening ball
games so I think the key is here we can
start May is going to be a transition
month okay we America will be better off
spirits will rise let's get back to the
booming economy that we had just a
couple of months ago all of the
president's incentives are still there
on taxes and regulation let's fight back
and play baseball and ribbon that's what
people want
let's play some baseball Jess and and
people and numbers will tell the story
it's very important people want
confidence people will have confidence
with the numbers but I think this is
very doable
chin up Jesse we're coming to America we
got it baby
here we go all right thank you very much
Larry all right